the millisecond my hands left the rail
and my legs cleared it
i had an instantaneous regret for my
actions
i fell near nearly 250 feet 25 stories
closing in on 80 miles per hour nearing
the speed of terminal velocity in four
seconds
in those four seconds
i said to myself what have i just done
and i want to die god please save me
and then i hit the water
[Music]
my infancy was extremely traumatic
i was born
to biological parents as i'm adopted
who had manic depression
what we today call bipolar disorder
and after they had me and my brother
jordash
they succumbed
to hardcore drugs and alcohol
that's how they coped with their mental
illness
we lived
in and out of crack motels
in the worst neighborhood in san
francisco then
the worst neighborhood in san francisco
today
one one fateful day
a seedy motel clerk
made what i've always called his most
unseedy decision
he heard my brother and i screams and
cries
from being neglected
left alone
as my birth parents went to do score
sell drugs
and he called the police
police came in barreled down the door
and they picked us up smelling sour and
putrid of our own filth
lying on a box spring for a mattress
over a concrete slab floor that if we
had fallen to we could have died
they took us into protective custody
they placed us
into the foster care system
a broken system
the same system that allows kids to age
out into 18 and homelessness without a
penny in their pockets
allowing other kids to be abused and
neglected by the very foster parents set
to protect them
my brother and i bounced around from
home to home for a bit with one
very simple idea
that he and i
were to be adopted together
in one of those homes filled with
neglect we both got a vicious strain of
bronchitis
and my only full-blooded brother jordash
died
he was the closest person to me
and he disappeared
when i was in one of the foster care
facilities
where they were trying to determine what
home to go to next
my birth parents showed up and kidnapped
me
went on the run for four weeks
feeding me kool-aid coca-cola and sour
milk because that's what they could
steal
they returned
me to the foster care system
when they were tired and they couldn't
do it anymore
i know they loved me
because over the next two years they
fought in a court hearing for custody of
me
against patrick and deborah hines
but unlike my brother
i got lucky
i of course landed in pat debbie heinz's
home
and they made me their son
what sort of child were you
i was
i was an abundance of energy i was like
a big ball of energy i was
excitable
extremely sensitive i still am
can't deny that
and uh i
loved
life
i loved being involved in
all kinds of activities
i played all kinds of sports
i would
i would drop
everything to go
outside and play with the kids around my
neighborhood
we would do you know
roller hockey on the on the street
with the street puck i mean we we had a
blast
the sensitivity thing though i i
i really
took everything
personally
that everything negative i took it
um i took it to heart
and it would the small the smallest of
things would destroy me
when did you remember
first feeling or thinking that you had
some
issues with your mental health
you know this is something i don't i
don't talk about much
in fourth grade
right before i had my first epileptic
seizure
i saw demons
in my room
i was laying there
in bed
and i saw these dark shadows
cross
the
the top
edges of the room
these things had eyes red bright red
burning eyes
and they came down and they they came
right here
right next to me
it was terrifying
and i was motionless i couldn't move it
was almost like a sleep paralysis
situation which i've dealt with as an
adult as well but i didn't tell anybody
about it
i i was i was a child i didn't know how
to express myself i didn't know how to
articulate
what i was seeing
and the other thing is in in the same
year in fourth grade i i began to hear
voices
they were murmurs i couldn't quite
understand what they were saying
but
they were angry
and i knew they hated
me i think that was the first time i i
realized
without realizing it
that i was
going through something very profound
and scary
do you ever think of the issues that
you've had to face and overcome with
your mental health being linked to your
traumatic start in the world
if i had been
from birth
taken care of properly fed properly
given the nutrition i needed
the love and the care and empathy i
needed
and the compassion i deserved
we wouldn't be sitting here right now
having this conversation
my life would be majorly different
and they played a major role
in
[Music]
me
in my mind breaking
in the year
1999.
could you talk to us about the events
leading up to that day
and the day itself and what happened
at 17 years of age
you know i had i had been
a wcl wrestling champion
i had been in speech and debate
i joined the swim team
[Music]
i was doing all these extracurricular
activities
i stood on a stage
at archbishop reardon high school
and i'm on stage stage right my left
looking out in this crowd
and in a fit of extreme
paranoid delusion i begin to believe
that every single one of the people in
this audience
is going to simultaneously rise rushed
the stage and then my life
it was the first severe symptom i ever
had i'd had symptoms i'd had
hallucinations auditory and visual
paranoid delusions manias and
depressions all of that i was keeping
under wraps telling no one
because i was terrified that they would
lock me up in a white walled padded room
and throw away the key
and i penned that note
the note to my mom and my dad and my
brother and my sister
and my best friend and my girlfriend at
the time
i told them i loved them
i told them i was sorry
i asked for their forgiveness
on september
25th the year 2000 the day after i wrote
that note
well to be fair i hadn't slept in 14
days but two hours
so i was completely psychotic all by
itself add that to my bipolar diagnosis
i was a mess
at six in the morning on the
25th of september of the year 2000 i
entered my father's room
he lied there sleeping wearing a
breathing apparatus a sleep apnea
machine
i startled him awake and he looked at me
he said kevin what's wrong
and i wanted to tell them
i wanted to tell them everything
but i couldn't
i couldn't get the words out
i couldn't express myself
i was stymied and halted by the voices
in my head telling me i had to die
and they would win the day
i lied to my dad
fine dad just wanted to tell you i love
you
because i thought it was the very last
time
he looked at me goes kev i love you too
but at six in the morning i don't have
to be working until nine go back to bed
and he fell as soundly asleep as quickly
as he'd awoken
i walked around the other side of the
bed sat on the carpeted floor and rocked
my body back and forth in tears in a
cross-legged position begging myself to
tell the one man who loved me the most
in the world the truth
but i couldn't
at 6 30 i went back to my room
at seven he entered
and he gave me another opportunity to
tell my truth
kevin why don't you come to work with me
today i'm worried about you
sorry dad can't do that i gotta be at
city college today
kevin will go to the beach no dad can't
do it really got to go to city college
kevin go to the movies kevin will do
whatever you want i just feel like you
need to be with me today he was so close
yet so far away
nobody taught my father patrick kevin
hines
the tools of suicide prevention what
parent is before it's too late
nobody taught my dad
that by asking the direct blunt and
honest questions are you thinking of
killing yourself have you made plans to
take your life and do you have the means
you get a more honest answer than even
the words are you thinking of suicide
because of the taboo on the word suicide
or even the terms have you considered
self-harm because by definition
self-harm is not suicide it's self-harm
nobody taught my dad that
and i said to him
dad
i have a math test today
you couldn't pay me to take a math test
any day
you would never see me be excited to
take a math test but on this day i was
i had become what suicidologists and
suicide preventionists call ambivalent
i believed i had to die
but i desperately wanted to live
my dad says to me kevin i'll tell you
what i'll take you to city college you
take the bus home i'll see you home at
six tonight
sounds good dad
we got to this corner of the city
college campus
and he turned to me
and he said one of his favorite mantras
kevin
i love you
be careful
the man said it every day
he calls me today just to say it
and we are very lucky that he can
i got onto a bus i sat in the very back
row in the middle seat looking out upon
what ended up being 100 people on that
bus
and i began to cry softly
moderately and then waterfalls flowing
from my eyes mucus to me from my nose
and then i began to scream aloud on a
crowded bus filled with people at the
voices i was hearing in my head
leave me alone
but i don't want to die
why do you hate me so much what did i
ever do to you
to top my lungs
the bus got to the golden gate bridge
parking lot everybody d boards right
there
and i sat there crying hoping the driver
would see me
and see my pain
instead he stands turns looks at me and
says come on kid get off the bus i gotta
go
i walked up to that man
i looked him right in his eyes
as water flowed from mine
and he just motioned for me to get off
the bus
i walked across the two-mile stretch of
roadway that is the golden gate bridge
walkway
facing back and forth back and forth
for 40
minutes
crying like a baby
bikers
joggers
tourists
runners
police officers went by me twice
at that moment
i said to myself absolutely
no one cares
which was a complete and total lie
everybody cared
i remember my family
every one of my friends
my acquaintances would have been there
to rip me from that rail to safety had
they known where i was and what i was
doing
my brain wasn't allowing me to care
my brain was trying to kill me as i
tried to stay alive
desperately clinging to life
i said nobody cares
jump now
and i did
the millisecond my hands left the rail
and my legs cleared it
i had an instantaneous regret for my
actions
and as i fell
the absolute recognition that i had just
made the greatest mistake in my life and
it was too late
i fell nearly 250 feet 25 stories
closing in on 80 miles per hour nearing
the speed of terminal velocity in four
seconds in those four seconds
i said to myself what have i just done
and i want to die god please save me
and then i hit the water
hitting the water from that height at
that speed is like hitting a solid brick
wall
your body stops for less than a second
then a vacuum sucks you under 70 feet
upon impact i shattered three vertebrae
my t12 l1 and l2
and i missed severing my spinal cord by
two millimeters
i went down 70 feet i opened my eyes
and i was drowning
there i was
in that water tumultuously flipping back
and forth not knowing which way was up
or down i began to swim in any direction
i could not feel my legs they were
working i go down down down the water
gets darker and murkier my eyes bulged
my ears ring i knew i made a mistake i
shot for what i believed to be the
surface
as fast as my arms would take me
i got closer and closer to this lit
circle of water above me thinking i'm
not gonna make it
i remember saying to myself kevin you
can't die here you die here no one's
going to know you didn't want to
a woman driving by in a red car
saw me go over the rail at the moment of
my attempt
called her friend from her car phone
in the united states coast guard
who happened to be manning the waters of
the bridge at that very moment
the coast guard arrived
these wonderful officers got me onto
this flat board
put me in the neck brace strapped me in
head to toe and they started asking
questions as i was fully conscious
this was not just another body recovery
which is what they were expecting they
did not expect to find me
treading water
and alive
99 of the people
who have left off the golden gate bridge
never again get to share their stories
they're gone forever
in hospital
after my attempt
i would initially be in a bracing
structure
i would have to have a 10 and a half
hour back surgery to replace my
shattered vertebrae with titanium
i was in a world of pain
i was on so much morphine to mitigate
the pain
having so many hallucinations in the
hospital
seeing giant metallic spiders crawl
across the ceiling trying to eat me
seeing dragons fly in my room it was
absolutely wild
but as i healed up
you know my my mom came to see me and
said i guess god wanted you to win that
oscar i'm like mom i just did high
school in college theater calm down
my dad came in and he was crying and i'd
never seen the man cry in 19 years of my
life i never i didn't know he had tear
ducts such a tough old sunset irishman
you know
and
he was like toughest guy i knew and here
he is balling like a baby and he goes
kevin i'm sorry i said no dad i'm sorry
i'm in that hospital i'm getting better
physically
go to the psych ward
and we go home
a few days go by and
my dad goes okay kev we're going to
church
so we go to the church i grew up in the
church my wife and i would get married
in later
how are you
glad you came today how would you like
to come and talk to our seventh and
eighth grade class about your experience
this good friday
and that was coming up right around the
corner i was like oh father i don't have
a speech that i wouldn't know what to
say
and my dad took his oven mitt-sized
hands shoved me forward and goes i'll do
it
i was like what are you doing he's like
you'll do it we need closure
and when pat hines says things twice you
do it
he's 6-1 and i'm not
well i get to the
directory that day on good friday
and i walk into the room and there's a
hundred twenty seventh eighth grade kids
in their catholic uniforms that i used
to wear
cross laid on the floor ready to listen
intentionally you know
and they're looking at me and i'm really
thinking like oh god what am i doing
here
well i take the 17-page speech that i
wrote i typed up
and i begin
after an introduction from father
michael herrmann
and i'm dropping page by page to the
floor
it takes 45 minutes to read aloud i am
crying i'm shaking like a leaf i'm a
mess it's raw
father michael herman calls me
and says kevin would you come to the
rectory
um i've got i've got something i want to
i want to share with you and father
michael graham insists me down i take my
asthma inhaler because i can barely
breathe
and and and he says sit down and he
hands me a manila envelope
and he says open it and i open this
thick man envelope and inside of it is a
hand pencil colored drawing of the
sacred heart of jesus that one of the
kids did it was beautiful
and inside that
was 120 letters
from 120 kids
now i'm no fool they were mandated to
write the letters 120 kids didn't get
together and go let's all write to the
suicidal guy simultaneously
no but they wrote they wrote their
letters nonetheless and they were given
no parameters on what they could write
free reign
well they wrote to their hearts content
and six of them were actively suicidal
and they wrote that in their letters
and those kids were given the mental
health help they needed and they're
alive today
when my father read those letters he
looked at me and he said kevin
we have to do this however
wherever and whenever possible
and we can't stop
and since then
i've traveled around the world
speaking to audiences of all kinds
ranging from the military to law
enforcement to the fbi to high school
college and
grade school students
to organizations uh
any group you can imagine hospital
associations i've done it
what advice would you give to people out
there suffering with their mental health
or in fact anyone who wants to look
after their brain health
every time i'm suicidal today
i turn to
anyone
willing to listen to me
and i say four simple
but very effective words
i need
help
now
it's not necessarily always the first
second third even fourth person i tell
that to that's going to get my back
because not everybody can handle that
kind of pain
but by the sheer
probability
of the number of people i request that
to someone has always been willing to
empathize with me and get me to a safe
place albeit mostly my lovely wife
margaret
or my father my family or my friends
but when i'm with none of them
when i'm by myself at an airport i have
gone in atlanta to the tsa agent and
said i need help now they're like what
do you mean buddy i said i'm suicidal
i'm freaking out and they go well come
with us and they put me in a locked room
they do a threat assessment
but they got me the help i needed they
could have put me on the no fly list but
they got me the help i needed
and each and every time
i need to go into a psychiatric hospital
because of my diagnosis and my struggles
after the first three involuntary stays
after my jump off the golden gate bridge
the next i would say four years after
the golden gate bridge jump
i have walked into those hospitals and
said i need to be here or i won't be
here
today
after what i did
i hold gratitude for everything
every place i get to go
everything i get to do
every single person i get to meet
because all of it almost didn't happen
it's a gift
call the crisis lifelines
text the text text lines reach out and
beg plead and ask for help because you
deserve it
you are valued you are loved you are
worthy and you matter and nobody can
tell you different
[Music]
yeah he said you know he said you know
um
you'll run him well and um you've got
this
this diagnosis schizophrenic disorder i
kind of thought my life was over as soon
as i got that diagnosis